well alright I know you're slammed in
everything and I know you're ready to
pass the torch to somebody else so it
was fun love you but ha well crap what
am I gonna do now and then looking
healthy with it I'll take a beer I tell
you what I really need a new co-host for
the ACM Awards somebody that loves
country music somebody that I'm a little
better looking than kind of like last
year
once the dance saying party in Vegas
there's got to be somebody out there
don't tip that on back sure we'll find
your answer
how hard can this be uh I got a lot of
friends I know a lot of people I just
need to look for sign I'll know it when
I see
so turks are you doing what are you
doing it's gonna bear Dierks oh my god
that's it I've been looking for sign all
day and you walk in the ball for what
what did you do in April 3rd I think I'm
around you got a good suit I got a great
suit then let's go to Vegas
and host the ACM Awards together the ACM
those they see him you and me me and you
you